head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
if we took Trump into santis and we made
a Venn diagram of everything they agreed
on where what are the differences that
you see that DeSantis doesn't have that
what is that what is that X Factor that
Trump does have that you're talking
about
well you just said it um Trump is Trump
is a once in a generation
um charismatic Authority
that cannot be replicated it cannot be
imitated uh
as somebody who has a little slice of
that kind of Charisma myself
um and has experienced uh
retinue of desperate clingers and
imitators in my life
um I can tell you it it never pans out
trying to you know uh
just snatch the bits that you can
stomach from the guy everybody loves and
otherwise keep serving your special
interests Trump is Trump is a
look whether you believe in God or not
um you could you could express this in
terms of ordainment if you wanted to
um you know or you could just say that
some people are born with a magical kind
of personality that captivates people in
a way that nobody else can can imitate
in terms of what people are getting
santis on the other hand has no
identifiable personality at all well
sure um but but what what what
symbol policy feeling do people get from
Trump what victory you're making the
mistake that all politically minded
people make um which is assuming that
people vote on the basis of policy how's
that feeling
uh
uh DeSantis has scored some victories in
Florida he's been an excellent governor
in Florida and that's where he should
stay because he's been a very successful
and excellent governor in Florida but as
I said people like him in some bits of
Florida almost as much as they like
Trump but ask him to choose I'm trying
to figure out on the the gain people get
from Trump they don't get from DeSantis
and and that can be emotional it's
precisely that it's precisely that
magical intangible that
um you the the
you try to articulate and stumble and
then when you go to a rally you're like
that's what I was talking about
schematics man it's vibration it
actually Alters DNA uh I I don't know
about that but yeah change the way
people's bodies sounds like nonsense but
um that's amazing that's why music can
heal people and stuff uh no um
but um but but there there are people
who are born with that um gift and uh
they typically find some
um uh way in which to to express it but
some of them become singers some of them
become actors uh and saying Trump exudes
really Charisma doesn't
quantify what's happening for us in a
way that you know so so for me right it
does
mesmerizing I get that he's get that but
what what do so so a lot of people are
motivated he's an intoxicant that plots
out the Sun what does a intelligent
political candidate who has a chance
what does an intelligent individual
organized person gain from that a good
feeling I don't know what kind of um
logical fallacy that is uh what does an
intelligent person gain well because
you're saying the average person doesn't
care about I can't speak for intelligent
people but um so so if no one actually
cares about what their politicians are
doing for them then what why should I
care about Trump over DeSantis Trump is
what Trump what happened in 2016 was
the last time that half this country
felt good about themselves and like
there might be hope
you cannot fight that hope for what
Trump what what what their world
wouldn't be ripped apart by uh social
engineering and by other things I can't
mention right now until the third hour
but there are things going on in this
country that that threaten the um very
basis of our civilization that stem from
original sins like women's suffrage but
go all the way through to more modern
fads and and manias uh to do with uh um
things we can't talk about but but
there is uh the the people are keenly
aware that
the
physical reality of the world they live
in the facts they took for granted are
being ripped apart by uh by the the
political descendants of um now I
understand I understand okay so Trump is
the Trump in 2016. I was very blessed to
have the opportunity to be such a big
part of that because
that was the last time that an entire
half of this country felt like things
might end up okay and he turned out to
be disappointing in office but how could
he ever have been any I I how could he
ever end up otherwise
um not appointed really horrible people
around him like John Bolton and Dr fauci
and put him in positions of power that's
one of them but one thing I want to
bring Trump has a weakness for his
family I want to ask why is it very
difficult to say I wanted to his family
I think but but that that's the answer
to your question the the reason that
people will will flock to him no matter
what even though they hate what he has
to say about
um uh certain medical things uh they
hate it they can't understand why he's
so proud of it they can't understand why
he never shuts up about it they just
want him to stop it's like do you know
who your base is bro
um but they'll forgive that and
everything because he was the last guy
that made them feel like justice and
hope so was was Within Reach I'll try
and I'll try and uh quantify it the way
I what I'm basically hearing is that
there are there are dark forces that are
destroying the fabric of the this
country Donald Trump stood in front of
that and and put a fist up and said
there might it might not be too late
um that you know so so when Christianity
comes into Europe in the Middle Ages
right it's it's it's real Innovation is
um a sort of joy and happiness that's
not fueled by uh self-indulgence and
self-destruction so uh Pagan societies
you know um people losing themselves in
music and substances uh there's always
kind of a cost attached to that kind of
ecstasy right you get you get yourself
caught up in some kind of um uh hypnotic
Pagan uh um you know uh trance thing uh
the nearest cognate we have these days
is uh drug-fueled EDM raids and it
always comes with a cost attached
there's a price to it
um when Christianity comes in the Middle
Ages you suddenly see like intensely
religious people singing and dancing
they found this way to be happy that
doesn't involve killing yourself uh in
some you know sort of slow motion
suicide
um people who are full of the joy of the
Incarnation and you have um you know
goggles pulling faces on on Cathedrals
you have religious people with smiles on
their faces
um one of the one of the
one of the emotional
capstones of Western Civilization is
that Joy
um you know another characteristic of
our artistic tradition is is yearning or
longing right most great works of art
are about reaching for something you
know about about that sort of romantic
frustration or whatever but but one of
the sort of the the emotional building
blocks of our civilization
um is joy joy in Christ happiness for
its own sake
um
I don't think anybody could plausibly
claim that um society's getting happier
and more joyful what we've seen with
runaway
um uh school nourishness and and
restrictions and regulations the kind of
um uh intolerable and oppressive
conditions under which some people uh
you know valiantly continue to labor
um
is a gradual suffocating of a joy
um
you know there's nothing recognizable as
comedy on television anymore
um well just really quick and that and
that well just just I'll I'll be quick
sorry
um that that that that
um
that gradual erosion of happiness
people feel that they're aware of it
they they won't articulate it in the way
that I did but they're aware of it and
they know that the last time that
something good happened
was this
crazy guy
that they remembered from a TV show who
suddenly
um suddenly inspired them with
confidence that maybe it wasn't too late
to beat back the hordes of hell yeah it
could be also the loss of religion and
the overindulgent society that is being
prioritized by big Tech social media but
when I want to specifically talk about
Trump because I did agree with a lot of
things you said specifically that he
does have a cult of personality he did
represent an idea that was going to help
the American middle class and it's a
demeaning um that's a that's a demeaning
minimization of what he had the cult of
personality is a is a is never a
compliment uh Cult of Personality means
that um somebody has managed to baffle
and bamboozle their followers into doing
destructive things cult of personality
is like maybe taking on a product I
would say shouldn't be taken that hasn't
been proven that has been operations
but I just want to specifically get to
the point of what happened today because
Trump's messaging doesn't look strong
today he came out and he talked about
how he got more votes in Florida during
his election he talked about how one of
his endorsements was wrong and he openly
threatened Ron DeSantis on Fox News
saying specifically that DeSantis is
going to hurt himself badly if he runs
and that he has some kind of dirt on him
that his wife doesn't even know that
he's going to release to the general
public this doesn't seem like a unifier
or someone who's going to bring the
party together and help the party
overall it seems like he's looking out
for himself let me add one even Picasso
had a blue period I mean Trump is Trump
is permitted a wobble given what he what
he's been subjected to he spent he spent
the past year just non-stop talking
about the past
I agree I agree and I think it's a
mistake yeah and I think that he
currently sounds pathetic and I think
that he needs to fix it real quick but
let me tell you the moment that guy that
gets his mojo back there isn't anybody
else on the field and and you best
believe that will happen that's a video
we should make you famous you best Trump
got his mojo back yes best believe that
will happen um shortly after he
announces when he has kind of I think
emotionally reinvested in in the fight
but this is a guy who Art of War this is
like your enemies thank you you're weak
when you're strong right is that what it
is I don't know if Trump thinks in those
terms I don't know if he's I'm only half
kidding I don't know if he's read a book
but
um uh I don't know if he's read his own
um but he doesn't need to because he is
has that gift that a couple of people
per generation have which is well you
know when they're in a good spot and
they're uh and they're you know firing
all cylinders they just have an
atavistic uh reflexive natural
understanding of
um of of of of of their people you know
um and he's an interesting he's
interesting anomaly because typically
you see this in Europe where there are
more
um uh explicitly established uh class
systems right
um so class operates in America but
everybody pretends it doesn't exist
which is why you don't really understand
half of what's Happening
um but
there's a weird Affinity between the
aristocracy and the working classes in
um European countries that retain some
Vestige of aristocratic systems and it's
and it's something to do with the fact
they live in the same places they both
live you know rurally in the countryside
they have some of the same Hobbies they
are involved in the same kinds of um
bits of the economy but they also have a
similar outlook on the world you know
they tend to be um uh conservationists
rather than environmentalists does that
make sense
um you know they they they were sort of
they have a kind of understanding that
the anxious middle classes the the
doctors teachers and lawyers who live in
big cities can't understand
Trump managed to pull that off in a way
that I don't know if any American really
ever has before Reagan maybe had a
little kind of dollop of it but not to
this extent Trump
perhaps because of his
um ludicrousness his uh putting his name
in gold on the side of his building so
on his plane the the sort of extravagant
and yet at the same time kind of
mid-brow mid-market version of opulence
that that he was showing people set him
so far apart from um or ordinary people
that he just managed to form this kind
of like weird but real bond in in in a
way I've only only seen previously in in
these you know in these um uh vestigial
class systems and and it's it's
something to do with the fact that when
he's listening to his own instincts
instead of um
certain family members and um uh like
Ivanka trunk that told him to bomb Syria
well her husband is the problem and
Jared Kushner who represents the
establishment and is tied to some really
seedy and and bad places and people well
Steve
um got fired for the same reason that um
I'm gonna get escorted out of here is
just finds it very difficult not to tell
the truth um uh so when he uh described
Ivanka as dumb as a box of rocks uh as
soon as I read it I was like yeah Steve
said that but this is my fear my life I
just want to bring this up really
quickly she's not she's not um she's not
a diabolical architect of her father's
destruction uh she's very easily
influenced
um uh a woman who's very in love with
her husband and anxious to maintain some
kind of social status independent of her
Father which means distinguishing
herself from yeah the views of his that
are unpopular with New York and I
absolutely agree with you but but aren't
you fearful that the establishment base
of the party has been kicked out or
prosecuted or is being currently put in
jail while the establishment wing of the
Trump Administration no the
anti-establishment is getting you know
thrown in jail has been kicked out has
been kicked out of his administration
and the pro-establishment side is still
surrounding him I don't think that um
whatever Petty humiliations visited upon
uh those brave enough to raise their
head above the parapet you know I don't
think there's ultimately inconsequential
um humiliations
have much of an effect at all uh like
ivanka's there but Ben's not
yes look just don't there are there are
those of us who are called compelled
um uh whatever whatever I didn't feel
like it it doesn't feel like much of a
choice to me it just feels like what I
was put here to do
um to uh charge out in front and
um
accept the cost of that and what comes
with it you know uh and and those sort
of spectacles those moments in culture
those moments in history
um they linger for decades they have an
effect vastly
um uh more complex and far-reaching than
uh people usually appreciate uh you know
and when when
people watched certain things happening
to
center-right popular funny guys
it will shape the thinking of Republican
voters for decades the fact that there
is a
that there is um for all of the Wailing
of the less left about systemic
Injustice which can never really be uh
located or convincingly
um uh explained there is
a hideous Injustice that has been
visited on them and and many of the
people that they have admired and loved
that stuff shapes the way that people
live and the way they think it shapes
their opinions of of new players on the
scenes on the scene
um there will always be sacrificial
Lambs um that doesn't in itself
mean anything bad usually the opposite
um
Martyrs are remembered for a reason yeah
but do you feel friendly do you feel let
down because you're one of the people
that was really behind Donald Trump so
were a lot of other people that were
censored that were punished that were
banned on social media and a lot of
people think that Trump was in a
position of power where he could have
stood up for his support or stood up for
all the individuals that were going down
taken down as he was in positions of
power do you feel like slighted in any
way where he could have done something
to Big Tech social media he could have
reigned them in and and he could have
also gone to parlor he could have also
stood up for free speech but but he
didn't I understand why a 70 year old
man might not have
comprehended the priority that that was
uh
look I watched the canceled Summit at
the White House and I noted like
everybody else that nobody who had
actually been canceled was invited yeah
it is a fact of historical record that
every year
um when the new interns came into the
White House they were asked if anybody
was a fan of Alex Jones or malianopolis
and if they said yes they were escorted
off the premises interns for Trump for
the White House in terms and you guys
were the big it happened every every
year that Trump was in office now Trump
Bears ultimate responsibility for his
hiring decisions but
the whole apparatus of the party
was deeply committed
to
to a business model
that Trump threatened to wreck in in you
know in in uh inside a generation the
gravy train might be over if he
succeeded
um
the
the antibody response you know that you
saw to Trump
was the
aggressive ruthless uh sociopathic
response of people who are wedded to
Earthly uh wishes
seeing their horde threatened by
somebody who could you know cast a spell
and impoverish them uh
I wouldn't want 2016-17 to have played
out any other way
what possible better story is there than
of these people who were it's like you
know people were robbed of us it sounds
conceited to say but
um you know this this fascinating and
exciting Corner well it wasn't a corner
it was was you know culture really was
sort of wiped out by bad people with bad
intentions and no one was ever held
accountable for it and everybody feels
poorer as a result
um you know without cancer culture you
wouldn't operate under the appalling
conditions that you do I don't know how
you do it every day I couldn't I
couldn't get up in the morning
um and and I I that's why I don't I
don't wish for it to go any differently
than it did
um I think the lasting impression
and the righteous indignation that that
produced is one of the most powerful
motivating
um uh energies behind the Republican
base thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time